[Music]
[Applause]
jim jackson one of our favorites nba on
tnt also works for the clippers a fox
analyst he was on the call tuesday night
game two warriors grizzlies
and the trio will be broadcasting game
four
jared greenberg iron eagle in san
francisco on monday at 10 eastern once
again on tnt jim thanks for joining us
uh let me start with the feeling that
you had in that game
that it felt like old playoff basketball
like these two really don't like each
other but they haven't played enough to
have that rivalry where
you know detroit and the bulls or the
celtics and the lake there's no history
there but when did you sense that this
was
big brother little brother little
brother was not going to put up with any
nonsense
our coaches meetings
um because before the game we'll get
into uh you know dream room and we'll
we'll talk to each coach and kind of go
over
you know just some questions about game
plan again and then one thing that
you know taylor jenkins talked about was
that they the memphis grizzlies were
going to be more physical
in regards to the game because it meant
so much that uh they were close you know
in game one but being a young team they
made some mistakes and they felt that
they lost that game one
they weren't it wasn't the same when
they lost to minnesota you know it's a
young team your shoulders are slumped a
little bit you're kind of disappointed
they felt upbeat so from the beginning
of that and even steve kerr said it
in the meeting with him
that it was going to be a much more of a
physical game and you can kind of feel
the energy in the building
as it started to ramp up the clock
started to tick down you got to the
national anthem you looked at the focus
of the players on each side
knowing how important this game was to
both teams that it was going to be a
little bit different a little bit more
physical
a little choppy at times but
once again a great game
the difference between a hard foul
and a dirty foul a dirty play
is what
the intent
to me a lot of times you know a hard
foul
is i'm not gonna allow a guy to get a
basket i'm gonna grab him i'm gonna wrap
him up i'm not gonna try to hurt him but
i'm gonna try to influence the way that
he's going to the basket or he's
shooting a shot so he doesn't finish
a dirty file is when a guy you just
going to whack and you're going to take
a guy out
tell a dirty foul it's so obvious
did dylan bricks
is dylan brooks guilty of that
no to me i don't think that was a dirty
power what i do believe is that
once a guy leaves his feet now dylan
brooke is in the past is known to come
from behind and block a shot
but once gary payton took off to second
the impact of what dylan brooks did
magnified the whole play and it was a
flagrant two in in regards to according
to the rules because it was a wind-up it
was a swipe just like draymond green
okay draymond's wasn't as impactful and
i say it because brandon clark really
didn't get hurt if brandon clark gets
hurt
as he hits the ground because remember
brandon fell and he couldn't brace
himself so if he gets hurt
that magnifies that play even more and
that's the difference between the two i
think gp the second the way he came down
on that elbow
it was a tough play here and and i think
that is what really caused the outcry a
lot more is because of the the overall
injury well we look at the end result
because exactly you know if if uh
gary payton gets up
then there's not this outcry of this guy
should be suspended for game three i
mean it's a hard foul and then you
mentioned draymond green draymond green
was upset that the fans were cheering
that he was got hit in the side of the
head he was bleeding a little bit but
does draymond know that the reason why
they're doing that is what draymond did
in game one so the fans don't know if
he's bleeding or got a concussion he's
just flipping them off
well
they're mad at him from what happened in
game one
and then
don't you guys understand i could have
had a concussion i'm like that no they
they don't know that they don't they
don't know and draymond is my guy you
know i've been covering him since
michigan state and he's going to play
the way he's going to play and you know
we as athletes
we have a certain thing in our mind well
fans got to understand this part of it
well it don't work like that and again
his reputation precedes him i'd love to
play with draymond and the reason why is
because i know what i'm gonna get i know
it's a guy that's gonna play he's highly
intelligent high iq for the game he's
going to play defense do all the little
things but he's their enforcer so he's
built up this reputation over the years
good or bad so when there's a benefit of
the doubt
a lot of times if you're not a golden
state fan it's going the other way
when you're at an opposing team's arena
so when things like that happen
i'm not saying it's right to
to cheer when a guy gets hurt okay
at all
but it always happened
to an opposing player
who is not well liked from the
perspective of
reputation now if he played at memphis
they would love him to death oh yeah
they would love him to death that's
their kind of guy but because he's on
the opposing team
you know we as athletes are naive at
times to think that fans are going to
empathize with us a lot of times
uh in a competitive situation now again
i'm not saying that it's right or wrong
i'm not saying that it's right that fans
cheer heck no it's not but in the level
of competition they didn't know they
just saw draymond green get hit in the
face he was out
that was it
they were cheering that aspect because
of what happened in the game before
because draymond basically set the tone
in regards to what this series was going
to be all about with that hard physical
file
but i want draymond to be known for his
play because if i asked the regular fan
uh what kind of numbers did draymond
have in game one what did he have in
game two we used to know those numbers
now we don't it's draymond is getting
known for something more than that and
that would concern me if i'm steve kerr
i gotta have you in the game
i can't have you getting kicked out you
can be an instigator you can be an infor
you can do all those things do it in the
context of what we do and what we've
done
and and don't get yourself into
individual trouble and that's the only
thing i would take away from that
well but it's happened before right
2016.
and that's the problem here's the thing
is that with a player like draymond or
any player like that that
had to work his way to get to where he's
at not as physically gifted as a lot of
players so he had to use the thing in
between his ears he had to play more
physical he had to play a different
brand of basketball in order to be
successful the league worked out perfect
in regards to
it being a smaller league for draymond
to really compete at that fourth
position he figured it out as well as
anybody will be
one day a hall of famer and you're right
that his antics a lot of times
overshadow how intelligent a basketball
player he is i'm sure that even golden
state fans get frustrated with draymond
at time because kind of like a patrick
beverly
emphasis on being the top guy and making
hard plays can come back to hurt the
team at times at critical junctures of
the game and as a coach it's like okay
what's damn what's that bottom line
what's that gray area where i'm like
okay dre
i want you to be you but i don't need
you to be you in this situation because
it comes back to her
that's the dilemma you face when you
have a
tense player like a draymond green that
you gotta allow to be himself but if he
crosses that line against one more
playground two i know guess what
he's out and that totally changes how as
we saw
operates defensively
more importantly how they all
they they operate offensively
we're talking to jim jackson mba on tnt
also fox analyst he'll be on the call
monday at 10 eastern game four warriors
and the grizzlies did you call out john
marant for the game-winning shot when he
carried the ball and took four or five
steps there i mean
at some point it it becomes laughable
jim
that
and i'm not doing old school as much as
i'm doing no no you shouldn't be able to
have the your hand under the ball
and then he took at least four steps
two and a half and a quarter no
did he travel if that if that is if that
game is in san francisco is it called a
travel
it depends on who the referee crew is
because it was a play that steph made
he basically took the ball
over top of the defender
which is a carry
they didn't call it
so we can go back in between the game
and figure out some plays in between
where it was a carrier's a travel it was
a charge it was walk it was a block but
are they more likely to call a travel or
a carry now in the nba
that's a good question because they
don't call either no
no
that's the answer
here's the thing
the whole thing is going to be
consistency if this is how you're going
i think players and coaches want this
from officials and officials have a
tough job because they're graded out
each and every game
in order to get to this part of the
playoffs you know you got to have a
certain amount of points lined up in
order to build up to get to referee to
official a playoff game let alone the
champion and you know that was a carry
and you know it was a travel you know i
don't know it was a carry and i know
it's a traveler okay
so so
you know
accepted jim
apology if if the official doesn't call
it it wasn't a violation
right okay
uh phil jackson's role with the lakers
you're gonna bring him in to pick your
next head coach
what does this mean for lebron's future
in los angeles
more importantly how much control
are the is the lakers front office going
to have with the coach they pick see
here's the challenge with the lakers
jerry bus did a phenomenal job of
building you know this from the
beginning building stars because he
wanted to have star power because this
is la
so the lakers you know are enamored with
the back of the jersey a lot of time
instead of fit
whether that's from a coaching
perspective um from the players think
about it when mike d'antoni came and
they got the white house that wasn't a
fit
but dwight howard had a name he had a
brand
dwight howard didn't fit in mike
d'antoni system there was no way that
was going to work
so the question is going to be
allow the coast that you bring in to
actually have some
monster construction control where it's
going to fit and it's going to work
because if not then you're going to
bring in another coach that you're going
to kind of force pieces to have to fit
based on management and that's the issue
with the lady
you don't bring in the ty lue
he's won a championship he's been
trusted by lebron james but you want to
offer him a three-year deal and you want
to actually
kind of pick and choose his coaching
side
come on you i mean
that's the challenge you have and that's
why the laker job is so difficult
just based around
the philosophies in the front office
they've done it right for a long time
but they've also done it wrong
this is going to be very interesting to
see
phil's role
and who ultimately
choose to lead their franchise moving
forward how much power that coach has
over again roster control i just don't
see lebron sticking around for this
i i just don't you know you look around
they don't have any depth
they got westbrook and a.d
um what else do you have in the west you
know pelicans get zion back uh you're
gonna have the suns that are still there
even though chris gets a year older
golden state is still there uh denver
will get everybody yes you got all of
this
and and it's going to be better yeah
you you have to look around and go i'm
not going to win another championship
does lebron then say i gotta go
you know it's something big into the
mind of what he thinks because he's
always calculating what the next move is
and you know they don't have salary cap
their salary cap restricted too no
drafting so that's why they had to build
the roster the way they did with
one-year contracts this year and try to
trade to get a westbrook in order for it
to fit the challenge is moving forward
it's like okay
you can't move
that's going to be a challenge
um
a.d is tough because of injury
and if we do move that who's our future
because there's always have to be a star
some something there in la
um they are strapped i don't know what
lebron's ultimate goal is because
it's a moving target in regards to where
he wants to be in his career
okay because la was the next step i
think in his legacy he's won a
championship even though the asterisk
part of it was the bubble he's out in la
for other alternative things
business-wise which i'm not mad at
um but his mind is always calculating
thinking about what's next and i'm sure
he and rich paul have talked about this
numerous times about what it's going to
look like next year what what is this
team going to look like and i'm sure
abs
is being part of the fold as far as
being clutch
there's a trepidation there as far as
man a.d got to stay healthy that's the
only way we can get this thing done we
don't have a point guard in regards to
how it fits so it's going to be very
interesting to see the language the
communication what comes out you know
after the finals leading up to the draft
and free agency what's going to happen
with this team but well lebron
i just don't know where the calculation
is i don't think he satisfies where he's
at right now if you're watching on
peacock you can see that uh jim jackson
has quite a few
uh sneakers behind him so that i like i
like free stuff man okay you know
let's do uh let's do uh a guess here of
how many shoes jim jackson has um seat
and i'll start with you how many pairs
uh i'm gonna say 175. 175. marv what do
you think
i'm gonna say 250. 250. oh mark i like
my man mark paulie
in this room or total in that room
uh
105. all right pritzy 93 pairs of shoes
93.
can you give us a look around with your
computer there
the problem is you can't see that door
that's closed right there oh
that there's shoes
okay okay
so
that's the hidden door right there okay
and then there's some on the side
floor in boxes
i'm not pj tucker though
his shoe collection is ridiculous he has
custom shoes i'm not that young i just
like my adidas my nikes you know my
workout shoes he he gets the custom
stuff and different designs on it i'm a
little bit more playing i'm older man so
i'm gonna i'm gonna say uh
what i'm gonna say 300 pairs of tennis
shoes
clothes
i don't know i don't know that no i
don't know the number well give me a
guess
250
yeah okay
and that's it that's a rough estimation
because i continue to get more and it's
just that i love sneakers you know what
i mean but if you had to grab one pair
to get out of the house
i'm gonna do i'm always gonna do i'm a
head shorts air force one always because
they're versatile they didn't go in
anything okay so there's no special ones
like jordan gave you a pair of shoes or
any of that kobe any any of those things
no no no but those wouldn't be worn if
they gave them i know but you got to get
out of the house with one pair
oh all you mean i just got to leave yeah
like that's you only get to save one
pair of shoes
i'm not setting the house on fire i'm
saying you're okay
i thought you were kicking me out
sitting in the house no no no no no no
hypothetical
one pair of shoes to get out of the
house with
oh man
um you know what
if it was one pair
i'll probably do the carolina blue
these are all all my favorite jordan man
those are nice
right here
you should have gotten jordan to
autograph those
no
i had enough encounters with him during
my career
if you asked him
oh yeah he would mike and i you know
here's a funny story about the shoes uh
i'm playing for the next and we beat
them this is 96 97 year we beat them in
new jersey so we go to chicago to play
some people told the story they didn't
tell it right
so we're playing
they want to get back because we beat
them
and sam kissel and i had a really good
game so mike and i are going back and
forth just talking you can't guard me i
can't guard you blah blah blah we going
back we lose the game i had 33 mike had
30 something so we're going through the
the the line to shake hands afterwards
and joe klein that played for the bulls
before pulls mike to the side and says
mike then leave my man j.j hello my
young father mike said no j.j is my guy
but tell him that's why he's wearing my
shoes
it is weird to play against a guy you're
wearing his shoes jim
hella hella trash right but
i said i'm gonna continue to wear them
too so what so but that's that's my
jordan story on the shoes because that
right there was become back of all just
done while you're wearing my shirt
thank you jim as always great to talk to
you buddy okay good talking to you safe
travels jim jackson nba on tnt on the
call
monday game four with iron eagle and
jared greenberg that'll be on tnt we'll
close up shop after this